on this episode simon Sinek stops by
what's kind of cool actually
[Music]
you ask
this is
ask Gary B everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 226 of
the askgaryvee show I'm excited I have a
guest I actually have a pretty serious
focus on the fourth quarter here of not
doing too many guests getting back to
kind of the classic version even India
even indict Osgood Oh even India is here
so we're going pretty classic on the
show but I couldn't resist Sun and I got
some drinks together catching up and and
I thought it would be fun to have you on
the show so many of the people that
watch this or huge fans of yours thank
you
many you know as these worlds work many
would be discovering you for the first
time which excites me I'm excited to get
that email you know nine months from now
saying thank you so much for introducing
me to Simon so there's a lot of selfish
wants and needs here in this episode
some is a friend and somebody who I
really enjoy spending time with even
though we're both so busy it happens
infrequently but to the the percentage
of the audience that doesn't know who
you are why don't you give them a quick
little spiel for the world uh will
answer some questions my friend sure my
name is simon Sinek and i have a clear
vision of what i want to build in this
world I imagine a world in which the
vast majority of people wake up every
single morning inspired to go to work
feel safe when they're there and
returned home fulfilled at the end of
the day and everything I do whether it's
writing speaking teaching whatever it is
is devoted to helping to build that
world and you and have you always had
that for yourself hast decade and before
then I would say my career before then
was I didn't do it before then I had a
marketing consultant saying
got it yeah sorry I just told me I mean
I enjoyed myself I had a passion for
what I did but I said yeah I'm meandered
yeah I would say that you know my I
think my goals and my visions were very
much about me and about the business I
want to build this kind of business I
wanna make this kind of money yep and
that hasn't been for the past decade and
and so me knowing a little bit more and
adding a little more color for the group
you you speak you've written books
you're in a breakout speech at one of
the highest of levels want to talk about
that for a second yeah
a long time ago I did a 2009 as long as
it long as good there are some older
people that watch this it doesn't know I
wouldn't consider so [ __ ] long a car
I think in the social media ok a long
long time ago long time ago seven years
I gave it I gave I gave a TEDx talk in
Puget Sound Seattle and it's gained some
popularity on YouTube and the folks at
Ted calm at Ed decided to put it on Ted
calm and it went crazy it went crazy and
when did it go crazy when did that it
happened you didn't know 9 2009 and I
put it on Ted calm in May of 2010 yeah
it seems I mean like it just seems like
a lot of people have how many views did
that get last time I checked it's about
27 or 28 million yeah
monster Andi what you're slacking over
and I don't have to be 28 millions and
so I'm so look I won I won the internet
lottery I mean you know well I mean I
got lucky I was I got lucky and for one
more time for the the people that are
learning about you what real quick on
what was the general thesis of that so I
shared I shared as a talk of a theory
that I continue to espouse that I based
on an idea that called the golden circle
basically every single organization on
the planet every single one of us knows
what we do the things we sell the
services we offer some of us know how we
do it it's the the things that we think
make us stand out or differentiate us
from the other world outside but very
very few of us can clearly articulate
why we do what we did and if you look at
the greatest leaders everybody from
Martin Luther King to Steve Jobs those
with the capacity to inspire action and
those around them every single one of
them regardless of their of their
industry thinks acts and communicates
starting with why yep most of us talk
about what we do and then we try and
tell people how we're better but these
guys talk about division they talk about
their cause they talk about where
they're going and what they do simply
serves as the tangible proof of what
they believe and it profoundly changed
my life it continues to be the way in
which I organize information make
decisions set strategy all of it it's
the North Star it is the North Star and
I found a language that
made it really easy to understand and
actually the cool thing is actually
grounded in the biology of
decision-making so it's not like some
highfalutin management theory it's
actually grounded in how the brain
evolved and makes decisions and what
about your book world you've written now
what three third book yep yeah came out
today this is the deck is that what's in
there no what the hell I was super
pumped alike he's got a box you sent you
something I know but I lost it you lost
it so yeah I don't even read it read it
I've never read up I read like four
books in my life like Joe Namath life's
told you realize it only has like 200
words in it that sounds like a lot it's
a lot of pictures this time there's a
lot of pictures so what are the three
books I get playing with the first is
the first India I think it's time for
you to reassess and and re-enter the
ecosystem I feel like you know to dunk
and sin and all these characters nobody
can play up to the level of your quality
and so I think we're ready to raise the
bar yes but before we do that the first
book first book is start with why yes
which is deeper look into what I've
talked about yes I'm a TEDTalk
second book as leaders eat laughs yes
which is all about how where trust and
cooperation come from and how you build
trust if you are consider calling it
like leaders don't eat at all stuff that
sometimes happens that sometimes have
long said yeah that's all right
and this new one happens I want that to
get today is cool together is better
okay a little book of inspiration yeah
that's what it is and it's basically a
beautiful little illustrated book with
quotes and aphorisms but it's a metaphor
I tell a story of three little kids who
are dissatisfied with their playground
because of a bully in this case the
metaphor bringer being a bad boss and
people imagine having a different job or
going somewhere else or starting their
own business or whatever it is yeah and
the question is who has the courage to
do that yeah and so basically it's a
story of three little kids who find the
courage to follow their dreams because
they learn to help each other love it
yeah that's what it's about so all
across America we hope in the world we
hope to inspire people leaving
organizations three at a time five in
time ten yeah I'm good with that good in
here let's do it Oh a lot of videos
right
oh good video real question is good I
like this hi Gary being Simon I hope all
as well question that I have for y'all
is can somebody's personal why
on why they work for a business very
from the businesses why or is that just
never good thanks a lot
keep climbing oh if it's your business
the business is why in your wire exactly
the same thing
yeah but he's asking if he works for
Mortimer who knows the organization's
why me a lot of people your decisions
were a lot of that no veiners why sure
they may have separate wise within it
can they coexist here employees why and
works dry coexist and everybody wins
sure the simple answer is yes if they go
together everybody has their own unique
why and the organization has its own
unique well yes and if they are even go
together in a peanut butter and jelly
okay if they're compatible then you will
look to the people who have joined the
company and say ah you're a good fit you
belong here and they will see themselves
as a good fit and each one is is
mutually beneficial in other words it's
like any relationship you know you and
your wife have different wise but
they're compatible you see her as
helping you grow and she sees used etc
it's the exact same thing which is why
sometimes it is incompatible just is why
divorce rates are very high which is
which or people well I don't know it's
sometimes incompatible that's a decision
making problem okay um but it's also an
evolution problem right like if you
think about it
one's wise can be really aligned with
the organization's today and five years
from now they may not no absolutely not
not if both organ or time you say no to
that no to that so you're saying that
there's a your legacy one where you do I
want to give you more framed up it isn't
fascinated by your decision to say that
you're saying that things are frozen
frozen and that ones context of how the
world of for example that it's so frozen
but North Stars that one who's an
employee who's rolling quite along and
has a right but then child dies from
cancer along the way isn't reframed into
the context of where maybe it's not
aligned anymore no the word I would use
frozen you're saying that there can be
no growth when you use the word frozen
okay your why is fully formed by the
time you're in you're probably late
teens and the rest of your life is
simply an opportunity to live in balance
with your wire or not so the
decisions you make and so what your
whether somebody's living that's why I
said before which is as long as both
organized a both organization and person
are working hard to remain in consistent
with with their cause then it's then it
works fine now the example you give of
someone's child dying yes you know
tragedy doesn't form or change your wife
tragedy usually gives us an opportunity
to live our why because it makes
everything else in the world seem stupid
yes you know and that forces us to say
there's something bigger and more
important here very often tragedy pushes
us into why not the other way around not
pushes us away from it I totally agree
with you I think the most extreme things
that happen in people's lives actually
just accentuates the reality exaggerated
of who you really are it is that you
know that the test of someone is not
when everything is going great it's when
everything goes wrong but that were your
true colors show or or the more similar
to that but a slightly different version
for everybody I'm fascinated by people's
wealth and fame really not changing them
at all just finally exposing who they
actually are and that that's not a
tragedy that some hard theory a good
thing it's a hard thing but it's a real
thing absolutely right so yeah it yes
it's fine if they're different okay and
as long as they're compatible and this
is why you want to know your wine this
is why you want to find out the
companies why because otherwise you're
gonna make decisions based on money and
benefits and then there's not even it's
like making a decision but who to marry
based on I don't want to sidetrack the
show but it's it's funny I'm sitting
here it's why I'm so confident in what
I'm building at vaynermedia
because the platform is being built to
be in their benefit to reverse engineer
what they want based on their DNA
whether that is enormous ambition which
is then this is a platform for them to
create that or within a very closed
ecosystem to me or quite passive and
very nice work-life I have actual zero
emotion one way or the other of what
they actually want I just want to build
a framework in a platform that gives
them those options and I think that's
the great mistake that most businesses
isn't that what you preach in your work
as well hundred percent so it's yeah I
have no interest in so the why is clear
internally and externally a hundred
percent know just what you know because
to me otherwise everything crumbles in
its hypocrisy if you don't do that then
Matthew hey Gary Matt Lamarche here in
Atlanta Georgia hope you're doing well I
had a quick question about
self-awareness do you think it's more
about maturity and wisdom or is it
something that you're just built with
thanks so much for taking the time have
a great day okay so I've been talking a
lot about self-awareness yeah I love for
you to take the floor first maybe you
haven't had as much time to ponder this
this world um what's your take on
self-awareness you um do you feel like
you have it do you feel like it it grew
is it you know for example I believe it
is the ultimate power once you have that
boy can you start navigating I'm
struggling because so many people have
really caught attention to this and
you're asking me to help them figure out
how to gain more of it unlike Jesus this
is you know there's certain places where
your your skill set stops mine stops at
how am I gonna know I boy do I know the
people that I know that have it are
winning and and not just financially or
exposed like they're just in a happy
place because of that self-awareness
what is your thought on self-awareness
yeah I think it's a skill like any other
so you do think it's something that can
be mean some people might have natural
capacity for it but however they were
raised like any other skill you know in
the world some people are good at
basketball and some people to work very
hard to be good at best but it's do you
think one caps out though in a
basketball analogy dunk is a ISM is a
nice-looking athlete but he's never
going to be an NBA player he has a
ceiling of his basketball skills do you
think people have a ceiling of people
are the ceiling I don't know people have
a ceiling but I think self-awareness is
a skill a practice will learn learn
about skill and I think that the one one
of the big things about self-awareness
is we don't really know how we're being
perceived we think we know how we're
being yes and sometimes we act in a way
you know when we when we act all pompous
because we want to appear strong but
really we appear weak and that's right
you know you know we're not always aware
by just yeah right and so I think the
big thing about learning to be
self-aware is being open to the feedback
from people who love you and care about
you who are willing to say to you when
you said that you looked and sounded
like an ass yeah right it's fun and to
be open to that kind of harsh but from a
good place
critique is the only way to learn it's
funny with Democrats funny you said that
I think the closest I've ever gotten to
answer this is that and then comma
putting that inner circle in a safe
place to tell you the truth accurate
because those same people are scared
crap you know they love you and if
you're defensive the whole time they
came over then then you are not learning
self-awareness
I would I would tell you that my reading
of comments over the last decade on
social and taking each with a grain of
salt your biggest fans you can only you
can only let your ego go so far and you
know you're aware that some people troll
for the sake of getting reactions from
the community things that nature but the
net the millions in a net composite
score has definitely been I would always
say that listening has done a lot more
for me even though I love to talk and
always talk that consumption pattern has
been a very big deal so there's a
wonderful story
please listening has the problem when
people say you need to be a better
listener as we are human beings and we
need to communicate that communication
is two ways listening and speaking so
the but everybody like you got to be a
better listener like but here's the best
understanding I have that so Nelson
Mandela is universally regarded as a
great leader which is important because
you know different people are viewed
differently in different nations but
Nelson Mandela universally regarded as a
great leader right he was actually the
son of a tribal chief and he was asked
in an interview once how did you learn
to be a great leader and he tells the
story of how he would go to tribal
meetings with his father and he
remembers two things they always sat in
a circle and his father was always the
last to speak hmm and in terms of
leadership and listening I think the
idea of be a better listener is actually
half the advice I think the advice is
practice being the last to speak you see
this all the time in meetings where
everybody will sit around a room the
senior guy would be like all right
here's the problem here's what I think
we should do but I'm really interested
in what your thoughts are yes let's go
around the room it's too late you've
influenced Ukraine if Ukraine and people
ended pay people bend and mold as
opposed to saying here's a problem I'm
interested what you have to say without
saying anything and not even and having
this then here's this takes practice not
even even giving a hint whether you
agree or disagree if anything you ask
questions to learn more you get the
benefit of hearing everybody's opinion
everybody gets to feel heard and then
you get to render so I would tell you
and this is for people that are running
businesses that is a micro example of
the way up which is and I think makes a
ton of sense I would tell you Andy you
obviously direct
or to me you run our team I think people
would be stunned by how little we talk
at all like the the level of micro right
like the level of micromanagement I put
on like my version of that is actually
letting people do their thing and
watching it from speaking last when I
but I guess my punchline is by the time
I get into the meeting we're we're like
here's the problem with the amount of
listening that has been done because
I've created such a white canvas for the
leaders to do their thing and I can
watch it and contextualize what they're
doing is the macro version because once
you're in that meeting room that's
basically the the final pitch of what's
been going on over that period of time
okay yeah it's interesting it's
interesting I believe in that quite a
bit okay good I mean I I think I am the
other hand do think that all skills have
a max out at some level you're
hardwiring you know but that really
matters you can't you can't continue to
grow to the data no I think I think
that's the the black and white version
of that I think that you can continue to
make incremental steps but I think that
there are diminishing returns cuz
absolutely I believe they believe that
because I believe some people are just
delirious yeah in this chase that
they're gonna be at this upside of any
skill yeah and I've become and people
lose practicality of some level the
question is where is everybody
you know if here is the max out right
finishing return that's right the
problem with the question is is did you
stop because anybody even get here I
mean like the you know this table which
is why and which is why I'm always very
careful to not play too much to the
negative because I don't want somebody
to stop here yeah but at the same token
in a world where there's a lot of voices
and everybody can do everything we need
to level some level at the colony yeah
thank you Bill hey Gary and Simon my
name is Bill Clinton Bill Clinton books
calm I'm an adult coloring book
illustrator I live here at the Jersey
Shore make coloring books for grown-ups
up till now I've been a one-man band as
far as controlling my operation and
doing everything myself but I'm looking
to expand and start building a team do
you have any suggestions
as I grow to help new team members buy
into my Y or my mission as to why I'm
doing this is there any best practices
or ideas suggestions to help them buy
into what I'm trying to accomplish here
any suggestions would be great thanks a
lot and keep up the good work yeah sure
well it's suggestion well what well one
is having clarity of y which is somebody
you have to have the ability to talk
about or what you believe what you're
trying to build beyond the business
itself so he's into adult coloring books
what specific which puts him by the way
which puts him in a good spot to begin
with right I mean if you just think
about that in thesis yeah there's a lot
of like smiling that comes along with
that there's like a lot of positive
vibes if that's why he went into it it
could have been for some Zen calm thing
or some weird thing he's a really bad
guy deciding so managed children so I
think I don't think so so but but even
beyond the coloring books like what is
it that he imagines you know the ability
to talk about his vision and if he can't
talk about his Y in hard terms can he
tell stories of his own experiences or
people he admires that if somebody hears
enough of those stories that can kinda
get a sense of who he is what you'll
find is that that the better you are at
communicating your why people will want
to work for you regardless of the
opportunity that you afford them like
they want to be a part of it yeah we do
a little thing which we've been doing
for years and years and years called a
give-and-take whenever there's any kind
of relationship whether it's a an
outside partnership or even somebody who
joins our team we do something called a
give-and-take where we want somebody to
be selfish and selfless within the
relationship so not give and get but
give and take so we'll ask them what is
it that you have to give to us that you
have that you think that we need right
and they'll tell us and then we'll say
great what is it that you selfishly want
from us
and we want them to tell us what they
can get from us and I know that so many
when those when those things match you
have a balanced relationship because so
example I've had it with people you know
they'll tell me what they what they have
to offer and that's awesome because
that's what I want and then they'll say
what they have what they want to take
and they go oh I want to work with the
smart people I'm like plenty of smart
people what is it you want to take from
me they're like oh I want to help build
something
wonderful do that anywhere what do you
wanna take selfishly from me they can
get no worse and if they can't answer
the question
I won't engage in a relationship and the
reason is because in time the
relationship is unbalanced they're going
to be giving but they're not taking and
I don't even know how to give them what
they want then they'll complain they're
not making enough money or that because
it's not balanced that's right and I
think I think the other thing you know
as being out there a lot of people play
a lot of people play the reverse of that
yeah you know they want to give you
something that is very low in value and
they want something insane and weird hey
Jeremy I tweeted about your book now I
want a job with you I want you to
babysit my dog four times a week like
like it's insane with that right so it's
about balance and to me I've thought a
lot about that I think a lot about it I
call it 5149 I fully believe in that
yeah and then what I always think about
is how incredibly important it is to me
to slightly give a little bit more not
because I'm the greatest human ever
actually just think it's a leverage
point I think it's like I like the
feeling and I'm not sold that I don't
know if that makes me a good guy or a
bad guy it's just my it's my natural
state to slightly over deliver as close
to the middle as possible and I like
that so one of the richest guys in China
he might even be there since the Alibaba
guy not so much but but the one of the
richest guys in China he's a he's a real
estate developer and he always gives the
majority share to all his partners he
always does 5149 or if or even more
imbalanced and and somebody again sat
down with him an interview and said why
do I do never do 5050 deals why don't
you why do you give away the majority
stake in all your partnerships and you
smile is because everybody wants to do
business with me all right
you mean it's that easy tons of sense
yeah um I think to answer the question
in a little bit of detail I think you
have the benefit of being out there I
think all of us have the benefit of
being out there today and I think all of
us whether your audience and we we've
been at audience sizes of just starting
to where we are today whether your
audience is very large or quite small
they're always a small group of people
that are attracted to your message and I
think what I would do in this scenario
is if you're looking to hire that first
person I would look very hard at the
people that are engaging with your
content on social and start there I'm a
very big believer on that because I
think it's quite practical they've
already been self selected they're using
their free time
to comment on your stuff consume your
stuff and buy those coloring books and
so I think that's a very important place
I've had a normal smell success with
Wine Library and both made a medium
exact same way I have a passion for you
and your work that's right and by the
way VIN minute by the way by the way
sometimes you lose because they had a
vision of what they were attracted to
and then the reality is it's work or
this and that but but I I do like that
starting point from a practical nature
JJ hey Gary JJ at 97 on the Box in
Houston had a blast heavy on my show
earlier this year to talk about your new
book askgaryvee I've read the book it is
amazing I got a lot of good stuff from
it I've been sharing it with some of my
interns and my friends and co-workers so
thank you so much today I have a
question for you I'm really seeing a
book next month it's called without
bruises a journey some hope help and
healing it's telling my personal story
of being in a relationship with a
sociopath and you know going from mental
and emotional abuse well I am trying to
figure out do I stick with JJ who is the
radio personality to market this book or
do I need to stay away because I feel
like I can reach a bigger audience but
I'm not sure if that audience is really
ready for the role of the shaved hair
tattoos who's that the hip ah station so
maybe you can give me some advice on
that thanks Gary
I'll take this one first and you jump in
Simon J look the bottom line is it's not
1984 anymore it's 2016
the you're not gonna hide from who you
are people are gonna figure out you have
a shaved head and tattoos you can go
under a pseudo name you can go in
disguises they're going to figure out
who you are so I think everybody wins
when they go all in listen I you know I
first 60 episodes of Wine Library TV I
2006 ten years ago I was tempered a
little bit because I was scared that the
people on Wall Street and these rich
people that were buying hundreds of
thousands of dollars a year of wine for
me would realize I loved wrestling and
football and I cursed and I was jersey
doubt the truth is the second I realized
wait a minute if people like this
Oh with 80% of me what's really gonna
happen the second I went all-in on me it
became a totally different outcome and
really I've never looked back both in
the wine industry and Who I am today
there are plenty of people in the
marketing book world that don't love me
I think the closer one is to me I don't
know people you know there's a there's a
LinkedIn post right now where I saw
somebody write of like why Gary Vee is
really great at social media in the
first comment with four likes from other
people is I would want to do nothing
like Gary Vee and I'm like well there's
five people I mean you know you know and
I get it and I get it but I think what
you have to take pride in JJ and
everybody is if you can live a life
where the people that know you the best
like you the most you win I love that my
assistants we talk about India's one
week as my like the people that know
more about my trouthe win like as we've
gotten to know each other we've liked
each other more not less and that's the
game sure I mean what's the definition
of authenticity right everybody's like
trying to be authentic nobody talks
about what authenticity is authenticity
is saying and doing the things you
actually believe and so to create
divisions one of them is inherently
inauthentic so in one of them you're
either being dishonest or you're faking
it so oh your head JJ I'm Ching so
matching is what's assuming you are who
you are and you want to bring that
personality and at the end of the day
the more authentic you are in all of
your work the more the people who love
you for who you are will take your work
and will help spread it for you
those are champions but it's very hard
to even find champions if you're always
hedging and trying to be what somebody
else wants you to be did I think you've
got a mystery done America I really do
people like you for you and they like
your percent and especially if you're
you for example he's neither of us
neither of us fits the role that we
expect them and I show up to these
meetings and jeans and things and and
Gary you know he's curses and he
surfaces but but people like us for who
we are and the people who don't like us
where we are don't invite us and that's
totally fine I also think that you've
got understand the American psyche right
there nothing here as much about tattoos
and shaved heads and things of that
nature
America forgives everything except if
you're trying to deceive them like you
can literally do anything in this
country probably outside of murder and
get away with it as long as you don't
try to pull one
over on us right the presidents have
proved that the most famous people prove
that we will forgive all day but if you
try to make us a sucker because you're
trying to put one over on us and we hate
that that's it yeah be yourself one more
really yeah and it's hard to be yourself
it takes practice it's like the self
awareness thing right uh-huh
let's do it well Africa I love it
hi Gary my name is Benjamin Bella from
Nigeria West Africa
it's 216 a.m. in the morning here and
I'm grinding I hope this gets in my
question is short and simple to you and
Simon when do you know you have the
chops as a young person to start talking
when you have the resource to bucket but
your notes on all-time grids yet do you
start talking or do you document thank
you I I think you start talking it's the
whole thing as a process so you start
talking immediately I mean it takes a
long time to become an overnight success
right and I think for both of us and
everybody we know that we admire and who
has achieved anything they've been at
this a long time and they were walking
at it and by the way they weren't great
at the beginning they took go watch too
much earlier go watch early interviews
of Steve Jobs right early interviews of
Steve Jobs are fantastic he terrible and
he actually in one of them says I need
to go throw up because he's so nervous
about talking on camera he's he's
terrible and the point is he practices
any practices he practices he gets
better but he does it out loud and I
think the idea of hiding until it's
perfect it's it's a fool's game
I think you put yourself out there you
start your practice you practice out
live then you get feedback and you can
you can you grow on the other punch
you're just yeah you put it out there I
I would say the one thing that you may
be referring to that I talk about a lot
is it's tough to come out the gate at 22
and say this is the definitive thing
here's my advice but I think I think
talking to the world about you're truly
believe correct in the game is the game
I think what we're seeing on the
internet right now like I must watch
your I must I'm a business coach and I'm
going to teach you in the only business
I have is you're gonna pay me 20k and
I'm gonna teach you how to charge other
people down the ladder 20k to give you
like that
the bad stuff so you know your point of
view on the world and like what you
believe and where you come from that's
gold
your process that's why I talk a lot
about documenting instead of creating
it's just your truth um but I agree with
you I mean there's no substitute for
doing or the amount of people that wait
for the perfect thing and then never do
anything you know the most beautiful
thing when you're young and you can give
something to contribute is to admit that
you don't know everything admit that
you're you're learning yes you say I'm a
22 year old expert I can help you do X Y
& Z you actually it's not true you have
I mean there's so much more to learn and
everybody knows that and everybody who
is the kind of people that you want
everybody people that are attracted to
that are gonna do very little for you
besides some short-term degrees and if
you say look I'm in this business I'm
fascinated by it I'm growing fast I'm
learning fast
I'm still a student with the stuff but I
have this service to offer that humility
is unbelievably attractive and people
want to be a part of that because they
know you're showing up to learn not to I
don't know if you're paying attention is
but in Reverse what's happening is
people are renting expensive things
showing a [ __ ] lifestyle and
Instagram like you know going to like
they're asking their dad to take twenty
five thousand dollars out in cash from
the bank putting it on a bed taking a
picture then putting it back in the bed
like just complete nutter fraud and it
pisses me off
that's insane yeah and by the way like
it's just it's just a non winning game
and you only attract people who want the
worse not even who you are the worst the
worst anyway some it probably lying
question of the day every guess gets to
ask the question there you get to ask
them a question you'll get hundreds of
data points back in return that you can
adjust to both on Facebook and YouTube
so what would you like to ask the
vaynernation what is on your mind what
would you like to get a good solid
survey in return from I want to know if
whether you have your own business or
work for a bigger company I want to know
do you feel loved and supported by the
people around you do you feel that the
cultures in which you were
for the culture which you're building
are ones of cooperation and of trust or
do you feel like you have to keep your
guard up the whole time you can't really
trust anybody you definitely contrast
your boss I want to know that and if you
are feeling supported and loved tag that
person I think we are just not deploying
enough positivity and I think if
somebody's doing that amazing thing for
you they would feel very nice when this
shows up in their notifications and
realize they're doing that for you yeah
thanks very much for you let me pass one
ago thanks Logan you keep asking
questions we'll keep answering them
[Music]